And everybody, Dr. Cutters, again,
digging deeper into Hashimoto's disease
and understanding lab values and feedback loops,
mistakes come that they made by practitioners
and by patients not to ask for the right thing.
So we're gonna help to understand some lab results
and some alternating feedback loops
and Hashimoto's that could cause problems.
Remember, typically Hashimoto's is, you know,
taken care of by the average practitioner
in a linear fashion, meaning there's overt thyroid symptoms,
TSH or TSH, T3, T4s, tested,
diagnosed with hypo thyroid, never tested
for antibodies, never tested for any autoimmune disease
and then they're given T4 therapy,
which is synthroid or levoxyl thyroid hormones,
which are just T4 therapy.
And then they're retested on an annual basis.
So we're gonna see that this is not really
the way to handle this.
So understand, and I mentioned this in the other video
that TSH levels can bounce all over the place.
So if you just happen to go in,
let's say these are annual readings by somebody.
This person could have, you know,
abnormal TPO, ethyroclobulin antibodies,
abnormal T3 and T4 and free T3 and T4,
but they're only getting their TSH checked and it's normal.
And it's normal again the next year.
And then it's high, and they're diagnosed with Hashi Botos,
or they're diagnosed with hypo thyroid,
I mean, they're put on some sort of T4 medication
and they go out of the next year and it's high again.
So they're maybe, you know, put on a higher dose.
And this is just not managed correctly.
Your TSH can bounce all over the place.
This could be literally daily values,
certainly weekly values,
certainly absolutely monthly values.
Your TSH can be bouncing all over it.
That's not the correct way to manage
or to evaluate a disorder.
So, and remember in any, all my other videos,
you don't just look at one test to evaluate anything.
So you look at multiple tests.
You have to look at subjective and objective findings.
You gotta evaluate the person as thoroughly as possible.
So remember, your hypo thalamus releases
a horrible to tell your pituitary
to release a horrible to tell your thyroid
to release its hormones.
And then you have these negative feedback loops.
So that's how these hormones work.
You have these, if you have XST3 and T4,
it will shut off your hypo thalamus.
It will shut off your pituitary gland
and it will decrease the TSH and it will decrease
then your T3 and T4.
That's how it's supposed to work.
So that's how you keep a normal balance.
The problem comes in is that a person can have,
if you have truly have, you know, Hashimoto's,
you're gonna have decreased production of T3 and T4,
at least initially, and you're gonna have reduced levels
of T4 and T3.
And then the idea is that you're gonna have
elevated hypo thalamus and elevated pituitary
hormone production.
So you're gonna have an elevation of TSH
and that's how typically hypo thyroid is diagnosed.
This is the perfect little case scenario.
Person comes in, they have elevated TSH
and it's explained because you have low T3 and T4.
Therefore, because of low T3 and T3 and T4
it's stimulating excess production of TSH,
thyroid stimulating hormone to get the thyroid
to produce more hormones.
What's the problem is, remember I just talked about
your TSH can bounce all over the place.
So this is really the scenario that can take place.
A person can have an autoimmune attack
on their thyroid gland and because of that autoimmune attack,
the thyroid tissue destruction can lead to an increased level
of T3 and T4.
So you can have increased T3 and T4
which that will be a negative feedback loop
and shut down TSH production.
So you can have normal or low TSH
going in with all these symptoms.
You go in, oh, I got some tired all the time.
I can't figure it out, I can't lose weight.
I'm losing the third of my lateral eyebrows.
I don't feel well in this whole barrage of symptoms.
But you get TSH tested and it could be normal.
Or it could even be low at this point
and you don't have a diagnosis of thyroid
and this is where this person is put out
at the anxieties and at the antidepressants
because they don't have a thyroid issue
because not because they don't have a thyroid issue
because it wasn't properly evaluated.
This is a criminal, but you see this going out all the time.
So clinical pearl of this is in the early stages
of Hashimoto's, the thyroid levels of TSH, T4, T3,
3T3, 3T4 can be normal.
Those can all be normal.
So you have to test for TPO and thyroglobulin antibodies.
You have to, it's just a must.
So once you have a diagnosis,
because most people listening to this
is like already, no, I have Hashimoto's.
Well, then you have to ask the question,
you know, am I stable?
Is my autoimmune reactivity stable?
So is it bouncing all over the place?
You know, Hashimoto's, Graves,
bouncing back and forth, what's that really Graves?
But hyper versus hypothyroid.
Or am I pretty stable and pretty balanced?
Even stable low, that's what we're looking for.
So we have to look at,
do I have clinical findings of hyperactive response?
So if I have a hyperactive response,
we need too much T3.
I could have heart palpitations, intolerance to heat,
inward trembling.
I hear a lot of times I feel like I got the eBGBs.
I feel like I got ants crawling inside of me.
I can't really figure it out.
Exiting inner angst, increase heart rate, insomnia,
muscle loss, sweating for no reason,
increase bowel motility, and most likely,
you're not going to have all of these.
It could just be a couple of these.
There's different exam findings
that you're going to want to talk to your doctor about.
In lab findings, you can have an increase thyroid hormones
but not hyperthyroid.
So if your TSH levels are low,
beating below 1.0,
your free T3 can be normal.
Your free T4 can be normal.
But you still have an increase tissue breakdown
or an increase in thyroid, too much thyroid
in a place where hormone could do this too.
Even too much natural thyroid supplements can cause this.
So if you're getting these symptoms,
you have to look at,
am I taking too much of my supplements back off on that?
Am I taking too much of my thyroid replacement medication?
You need to talk to your doctor
about backing off on that.
Or do I really have hyperthyroidism?
So hyperthyroidism would be a low TSH
at free T3 and a free T4.
Elevated can still be normal.
Remember, that can fluctuate throughout the day.
And you want to evaluate Graves' disease.
Because Graves' disease I've said in a previous video
is very serious.
You do not try to manage that alternatively.
You need to get to a prescribing physician
who can give medication to lower the T3.
Because this can be dangerous.
It could cause stroke issues.
It could cause heart attack issues.
This is very dangerous.
But the difference between Graves' disease
and hyperactive Hashimoto's is this.
So with Graves' disease,
you're going to have TSH antibodies as well.
You're going to have positive TPO antibodies,
positive thyroid globulin antibodies.
But you're also going to have that positive TSH antibodies.
If you have Hashimoto's that's just in a hyperactive state,
you're going to have positive TPO antibodies
and or positive thyroid globulin antibodies.
But you're going to have negative TSH antibodies.
That's the difference.
If you truly have Graves' disease, I need to stress this.
Get to a prescribing physician that can deal with that
medically.
You have to do with do that.
It's very, very important.
You will have most likely suppressed TSH elevated T3 and T4
with Hashimoto's that's fluctuating
between hyperthyroidism, hypothyroidism.
You could have either elevated or lower TSH
get at a given time elevated or lower T3 and T4
at any given time.
So make sure you're looking at that.
Secondly, steps to consider with Hashimoto's.
I said, is the patient thyroid auto-immunity?
Is it reactive?
Is it stable?
Even if you're stable at a hypofunction,
at least it's easier to work with.
Second question is, how aggressive is the autoimmune disease?
How much bouncing around is going on?
And the key component to this is, is there a constant need
to increase thyroid replacement medication dosage?
So, perfect example.
Here's a graph.
Year one, two, three, four, five.
Every year this person goes in because that's typically
the clinical management you're going in once a year
to get your TSH level checked, which is totally inappropriate.
But let's say it's elevated every year.
The person's symptoms continue to get worsened
and they continue each year to have to increase
their dosage of their medication.
This is a sign of an aggressive progression
of an autoimmune response.
The problem with that is that it's not going to only be attacking
the thyroid, it's going to be attacking other organs
if your TSH is normal throughout those years.
Again, still improper management in my opinion.
But let's say my symptoms are really balanced
and I'm really not having any issues
and I'm on X amount of dosage of my medication
or my nutritional supplement and I feeling pretty balanced.
Then we know our autoimmune disease is not aggressive,
which is highly beneficial because when you get into understanding
what hypothyroidism really does to the body,
it affects the brain, it affects the GI tract,
the bone, the muscle, it affects your metabolism,
it affects your blood vessels,
it affects your immune system elsewhere.
It can be leading to other and worsen autoimmune diseases.
So good time to pause this slide and just read through
these things but these are the kind of symptoms
that maybe you wire listening to this video
in the first place.
So we have to dig into these things
and we're going to on further videos.
So the key concept is thyroid antibody levels
are not associated with the severity of disease.
I get that a lot.
Well, my antibody levels dropped, that's good.
Well, that's great, but that doesn't mean
that it's completely independent of how much attack
is on the thyroid.
It's completely independent upon how much medication
or nutritional supplements the person should be on your thyroid.
Antibody levels are not associated
with the severity of the disease.
You could have just slightly elevated TPO antibodies
or thyroid gland antibodies.
That's indicative of autoimmune disease.
You could have super high elevation.
That doesn't mean that it's worse.
It doesn't mean that a lower one is better.
We're just looking at baseline and we're looking at relapses.
So to evaluate the progress of the patient under care,
you need to evaluate the whole clinical picture.
Again, not just TSH, not just T3 and T4.
You have to look at free T3, free T4.
You have to look at signs and symptoms.
And certainly not doing it just once a year
because things change throughout the year.
So a clinical pearl is you have to decide
on more regular testing.
Either get yourself tested quarterly
or monthly if needed or do a better job at monitoring
your signs and symptoms.
You have to understand the signs and symptoms
of the full picture of Hashimoto's
and further autoimmune diseases.
And you have to manage those.
If there's changes in your signs and symptoms,
either get tested or adjust your nutrition
or get into your doctor, get another lab,
get a proper lab testing and adjust your medication.
Check on triggers and we're going to go through
all the different triggers that you've been through
looking at triggers of autoimmune disease
through the other modules and we're going to go through
more triggers that pertain more to Hashimoto's
and how to deal with those.
Lot to learn, I get it.
But stay with me.
We got a lot to teach through just this Hashimoto's segment.
So don't give up, know that I pray in for you
and we're going to continue to study through this.